on les appelle les étoiles d'immersion
en louisiane ces jeunes qui contre vents
et marées ont choisi le français
4000 élèves du primaire et secondaire
qui apprennent les temps de vivre dans
la langue de leurs ancêtres
qu'est-ce que tu m'aimes
ils ne sont plus seulement fils et
filles de cajun ils sont de toutes
origines
l'amour de la langue et la fierté de la
parler les unissent beaucoup de
personnes dit que c'est le bon dieu de
l'amour fabuleux parce que l ouémé et
lui on a beaucoup chanté et on aime
aussi beaucoup parler le français
non
j'ai une chanson de dans mon coeur est à
céder aux accents rap poétique et
populaire
une chanson qui raconte la vie de ces
jeunes louisianais de quand on rentre
dans une modernité on n'est pas en train
de faire du folklore zachary richard a
réuni ses enfants de partout en
louisiane ça résonne dans leurs coeurs
et dans leurs yeux parce que je vois que
ça brille
une louisiane que zachary richard chante
depuis plus de 30 ans
il passe maintenant le flambeau à une
nouvelle génération
tu penses que tu vas continuer toi
parler le français quand il est plus
vieux
oui hommes parce que c'est mon héritage
la musique indienne mais danser
un héritage qui ne sera pas facile de
transmettre dans cette belle louisiane
déterminé messager
ici christian latreille radio-canada à
lafayette en louisiane
hélas